let's take you live to Hiroshima in
Japan now where you can see the G7
leaders as well as the extra leaders
who've been invited to that Summit are
gathering for was known colloquently as
the family photo where they all line up
um
head of the the main talks that are
going on you'll be able to pick out and
several of of the key players there as
they they clearly have set places where
they all have to stand
um for this photo so there they are all
ready to pose and ahead of this meeting
which has focused a great deal so far in
the discussions on Ukraine we had the
announcement from President Biden
yesterday that
um there he is as he approaches into
shot next to president macron and
Trudeau of Canada as well there as the
camera pans passed with Rishi United
there towards the end
um he has said that America would indeed
allow for F-16 Jets to be used in
Ukraine and they are American aircraft
so they have to give their permission
for other countries to supply them no
country has stepped forward yet to say
that they would but also they've said
that uh Pilots would be allowed to be
trained on them so that's the context
into which uh president zielinski from
Ukraine arrives at this Summit he
arrived just before 8 o'clock this
morning and will be joining in those
talks